i've personally always had a bit of an
affinity towards finding things that are
unexpected so i find it incredible that
here in dubai we do have this
world-class surfing community and and we
do have waves dubai is typically known
for the high-rises and five-star luxury
i think this kind of bohemian
underground surf culture mixing with
that is just a pretty beautiful thing
[Music]
my name is scott chambers and i'm the
founder and ceo of surf house dubai i
was born in sharjah in the uae the uae
was a very different place back then in
the 90s and
surfing culture was nearly non-existent
at the time
over the last 25 years the surf
community has grown tremendously
dubai actually sits in the ideal
location to pick up the best swirls that
come through the arabian gulf it just
makes it a very favorable place to learn
how to surf
friendship with farm started 20 years
back when we were in high school
together we shared the love for the
water and for surfing
scott
and a group of his friends were the
first surfers in dubai
a long time ago
and i saw them out in the water and i
wanted to do what they were doing and i
remember paddling out for my first time
and and catching that first wave and i
was totally hooked
as scott grew the surfing community
there was an opportunity for me to come
on board as a partner in the business
and us to create this new embassy
for the surfing community
to buy in the united arab emirates is a
is a place that supports small
businesses to grow and for people to
really create really innovative concepts
the exhilaration and and the connection
with the ocean is something that just
can't be described
it promotes that ocean culture that
ocean-minded uh consciousness of of our
environment surfing transcends cultures
nationalities uh it's so amazing to see
you know emiratis and non-emiratis both
get out in the water and have an
absolutely great time sharing the same
experience
at the end of the day we're trying to
share this love for the sport
and we do teach emiratis as well as
eastern and western expatriates and once
you're in there you never want to get
out
you